hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna talk about
scary stories to tell in the dark this
is produced by Guillermo del Toro which
means he made it that's how everyone's
interpreting another one on the pile
directors whose names people won't learn
this is from Andre Overlord as I call
him a little over a doll I do not know
how exactly the /eo gets pronounced from
that part of the world so is the V it's
the dog's Little John did you read the
books growing up cuz I did not yes I got
in trouble actually for checking these
books too much out of our school library
with miss June shouts out if you're
still alive I was always into spooky
stuff so I would read the stories but I
was especially captivated by the
illustrations hmm cuz those are chilly
that's what I hear is the most memorable
say I got in trouble for making out with
girls in the back of my pickup truck
well you missed out on a lot of nights
you could sleep times head banging to
you classic Metallica back in the day
yeah before we go into this I would like
to thank everyone who has downloaded to
follow us over on the Stardust over
there we do 30 second reaction reviews
for new film TV show and/or trailer you
can post your own stuff on there as well
completely free to download completely
free to use we talked about a lot of
things that we don't get to talk about
on YouTube and if you want to get our
opinions as early as possible follow us
there onto the movie review in it of
itself I quite enjoyed this film I
thought that it was really spooky it was
really fun I forgot it was pg-13 what
rating violent yeah really
net play that line of like we're all but
we're not quite there yet
so I didn't read the books so this was
my introduction to this whole world and
the lore I thought that the execution of
it was really tense I found it to be
kind of it's might be a weird word to
use I thought it was pretty sincere in
its approach a to go word felt pretty
trick
I would say classic yeah in a way yeah
definitely some of the elements of this
movie I've been criticized for you know
having overly familiar tropes that
you've seen in other horror films or
things that are cliche and in terms of
like reveals or understanding the
mystery of the of the story to me I'm
like nuts that's kind of the point in a
lot of ways it doesn't only rely on
those things and the stories themselves
are derived from urban legends and myths
and other things you know like yeah I
felt like I got the gist of it it's
called scary stories to tell in the dark
so it feels like classic I never likes
that around a campfire and told horror
stories but I imagine this is what it
was while you were making out with all
those girls you missed out on some great
comparing Pina yeah that's what we got
badges for this movie basically it takes
place in what the 60s 68 its revolving
around the time when Nixon is about to
be elected from president you know takes
place in a small town and there's this
group of kids think losers club think
stranger things you know the kind of
kids you're into for these sorts of
horror films you know regular relatable
small-town kids
yeah one's really kind of obnoxious and
irreverent and the other one is straight
man there's a girl in there this time
the girls the main character kind of
like all of the other ones the one girl
the group is big they stumble upon a
book in a haunted house and basically
this book starts writing stories that
start coming to life that involve the
main kids so think of it like this it's
a serialized anthology type of movie but
it's not exactly how that sounds because
there's a main narrative weaves in an
anthology tale but the anthology tale
doesn't like cutaway to look at
characters you have no idea who they are
it's an anthology tale of like a
different type of creature or monster
that involves one of the main characters
yeah it's kind of like a slasher movie
but if every time you cut away to a
character about to get slashed it's not
you know the same killer it's like a
totally different aesthetic with a
totally different ghost story themed
around it yeah and I thought that was a
really smart approach because from my
understanding that's not how the books
work so they had to well they're just
like little short stories
so they had to weave it in where he had
like an actual narrative and the
creatures in the film I thought were
great some stuff has been criticized for
lackluster CGI in certain elements for
me I didn't care how wasn't bothered the
filmmaking around it what it's doing and
how it's doing it is good enough to
drive the rest of the scariness home and
overall I thought they did use a nice
blend of practical CG and character
performance effects yeah all the
creatures are monsters everyone called
the ghouls they dare tease in the
trailer like with the Scarecrow the pale
lady yeah from the dream story the
Pillsbury Dough girl yes and interesting
characters people laugh and she first
came on and then then it was terrifying
as it proceeded and then the Zhi Jing
jingling man jangling man he's a great
character like the effects of him were
awesome yeah that was really cool as a
character that is comprised developments
from the stories but is kind of an
original addition to this like this is a
very direct film it's straightforward of
what it wants to do but because of that
it has a really great energy and pace
about it where I was always enveloped in
what was going on
granted I was always most interested
when you know one of these cool creature
stories was going on that's when it's
like the most fascinating you know
that's not supposed to be the most
exciting so and I so I thought it
handled that really well based off like
illustrations I've seen that people have
put up on social media I feel like it's
a good blend of what we've seen of del
Toro produce flicks plus traditional
scary stories to tell in the dark or
maybe scary stories to tell in the dark
was kind of the art style that has
influenced the works of Guillermo del
Toro that's more more likely the case
make sense if he would be involved in
this when you see the design the way of
how they captured the designs I thought
was great because they were so confident
and showcasing them and knowing when to
showcase them a lot of horror movies
kind of only showcase their monsters for
the jump-scare moment really flash into
like the conjuring you know the key to
make them scary is barely show them this
movie knew when to hide them when to
keep it mysterious when to have fun with
them when
have a little bit of camp with some of
the approach to certain characters here
but then also know when to just let's
put the camera on them this will
actually make it scarier if we stay with
the character on camera as opposed to
trying to mask it or hide it or not show
it moving you know yeah yeah yeah one
and that's the thing is they they also
let the characters become characters
over time so everybody who starts out in
as an archetype situations become
scarier as they become more kind of real
and this movie had like an emotional
core I wasn't expecting to because yeah
it's like there are 'if you all you know
I did while this is reminiscent of
certain things I thought of like the
hunting of Hill House or goose bumps or
ParaNorman they start out in their
archetypes and it's yeah there is a
familiar classic quality about this but
by the time we got a certain amount I
was just like yeah I'm invested in
everybody and I thought the girl who
Joey Margaret Coletti who played the
lead was like terrific kind of race
Randolph will disagree with you she
didn't do a lot with it I didn't think
she brought nearly as much the table
personality-wise as her co-stars and I
thought actually her glasses
particularly at the very end of the
movie did most of her work for them I
disagree with grace Randolph
oh I don't care two boards whatever two
wars it's coming at you yeah look out
man this was nice because I I think this
is an underserved corner YouTube Wars
scary stories camps are drama that's
right that's what I want to talk about
the lead let's get back and see what we
can do it starts a whole be futur iam
over here
Eli Roth what well anyway this movie did
something that a lot of other movies
lately have been telling me they want to
do which is go back to like those older
kind of like Amblin s core or like you
know kid-friendly horror movies where
there's like real peril but it's also
fun and a little nostalgic and and this
managed to do that without ever trying
to tell me or at least I never saw an
interview where they're like that's what
we're going for yeah this is a [ __ ]
like I think we both forgot what it was
rated at different time cuz it is like
intense nightmarish eerie unnerving
bone-chilling nipple chilling moments
yeah
ever go to the movies by myself and I
was by myself watching this and I was
pretty scared at times on the never
moment although twisting up and cringing
I went alone into definitely a movie
that's gonna make you squirm start off
with talking about it and I'll end it
with this I'm I'm very forgiving of
anything that felt like cliche or overly
reminiscent because I did feel like that
was the point you got like this main
bully character who we've seen a
gajillion times I felt like the point
was to do sort of archetype characters
like that for this world like it takes
place in the 60s but these characters
kind of feel like they're from the 50s
and then you have like the main dude
Ramon the movies pretty much telling you
he's like Mexican James Dean the movies
is pretty much sane yeah even the
archetypes play into the theme of the
fact that stories you know hurt and heal
and stuff like that and an archetype is
a story in and of itself you know and
then over time you know characters get
revealed in ways it's not that deep I
just think that it's well-crafted to
show up to watch Jason Statham and John
machete
this is a classic horror story and I and
I do think that it really succeeds in
elevating the parts that are familiar
playing them very genuinely it has a
really great cast I thought really well
incorporates the stuff from the book and
I do want to give some respect to Andre
over doll because I think he will get
overshadowed by guillermo del toro and
of all like the you know horror
directors on the rise because there are
a lot of guys with chops who get these
big opportunities the way he commanded
the direction and the shots are cool and
expressive and the editing is rhythmic
but it always felt in line with
everything that was going on it was just
like a really crisp example of like wow
this was the right choice of director I
mean it was it was like wonderfully
composed in terms of its cinematography
but it wasn't ever stylish for stylish
sake yeah exactly you know but it was
still stylish you know when it was still
nightmarish and yeah yeah I mean it's
know none which Gerald Itoro produced
you don't took place at totally that's
right all right guys well did you see
scary stories to tell in the dark would
you want a sequel do you prefer this
over it chapter 2 which Joker
you think is the best Joaquin Phoenix or
Heath Ledger you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell make sure to download and follow us
in the start us up and I would like to
give a patron of the day shout out to a
man named Harmon deep sing he's been a
pledge for just a short amount of time
and I'm always trying to get more words
out of him but it's kind of like pulling
teeth he's very short too it is a
responding to me but he's very kind I'm
not gonna say he's rude he's just you
know very brief he's 20 years old he's
from Vancouver Canada here's a photo of
his driver's life even though it works
in construction right now he has talked
about how he wouldn't mind venturing
into directing perhaps the horror job
which I find ironic because I looked up
his name and it means with person soul
of everyone's heart oh so if anything
you should be making movies like call me
by your name mm-hmm and not the haunting
of yeah you know ghosts of Girlfriends
Past ghost ship exactly very very very
good thanks elaboration thanks man
hey you work if you work construction
that's a free set right there and
construction sites are spooky anyway
well that's usually what characters do
at the beginning of a story before they
embark on their missions you should make
a horror movie about people making
horror they go into hiding